sorry
[Music]
there will be severe consequences it
will be absolutely wrong if I went into
the exact way we will react but Russia
knows that there will be severe
consequences and we are Vigilant and
ready to reactive something bad happens
[Music]
foreign
is Russia laying the groundwork for a
potential false flag attack of its own
we have seen before that Russia has
accused others for doing what they
intend to do themselves so therefore we
are sending a strong message to Moscow
that they should not try to use a false
pretext
as an excuse for escalation of the war
in Ukraine
foreign
[Music]
this may only be combat training but if
called upon these Fighters say they're
ready to strike
[Music]
you're the Secretary General of NATO
aboard a U.S aircraft carrier are you
poking the bear that we don't seek
conflict with Russia but of course when
we see more threats when we see a more
dangerous world it's even more important
that we send a clear message to any
potential adversary that we are there to
defend all allies because that's the
best way to prevent an attack and
preserve peace